welcome everyone to lecture number nine
in my Reckoning I think if my count is
correct maybe it isn't but yeah so where
are we so far so as you can see behind
me so so far what we have done is we
focused on physics informed new networks
of
pins and uh we have looked at algorithms
and in the last lecture what I tried to
give you was some theoretical insights
right and the main idea is to see when
pins work and when they don't work
especially when they don't work as you
will see today there are many many
conditions many many circumstances
situations where they don't work and I
think we have a good understanding of
that and so that's the main goal today
so today we are going to look at some
further theoretical insights into why
pins are going to fill right so by the
way just for the people in the room is
it okay when I'm highlighting on my
notepad is that okay or okay otherwise
because if if I use a pointer then
people on Zoom they can't follow so I'm
sort of constrained to do this okay so
let's uh recollect what we stopped at in
the last lecture which is online so
first of all we have some abstract pde
so this could be for instance a heat
equation we are going to see the heat
equation again and again today so this
is the heat equation for instance so
this is the differential operator and
all the sort of information the inputs
to the problem I'm measuring in terms of
or I'm giving them prescribing them
through this input here F this is the
source term the coefficients initial
conditions boundary conditions and so on
and the idea is that uh given F we have
to find U right so this is the rough
idea is that given F we have to find you
and to do this we are going to use pins
or ort of physics inform losses physics
inform new networks and just uh quickly
we have a neural network so U Theta and
instead of directly having labels to
supervise the data on what we do is that
we compute the PD residual because
that's the only information that we have
this is the residual of the PD and uh we
compute it we can compute it at any
point in the domain because of automatic
differentiation finite differences
whatever you call it and then we want to
minimize the integral here of course the
integrals can't be directly computed so
you have to rely on a quadri so this is
going to be our loss function right so
this is L of
theta
Sor why didn't that work yeah L of theta
and we optimize it with whatever some
variants of the stochastic radient so
this is pins and what we did in the last
lecture was that we sort of developed
some sort of a framework to analyze pins
and to that end so this goes down to
this paper I wrote some years
ago and essentially the idea is the
following that the the point is all the
time we have to work with three objects
right so one is the training error this
is related to the loss function right
this is essentially the square root of
the loss function L of theta then this
is the PD residual this is precisely the
PD residual this object here as you can
see so this is often called as
generalization error so you should think
of it as a PD
residual and the last object here is the
total error and the total error is given
by this quantity here this measures a
mismatch between what you compute with
the pins and what the actual ground
truth is what the solutions of the PD
are and the point was that as long as
three conditions hold this program works
and what are those three conditions the
first one essentially is this let's use
a different highlighting color is
essentially the smoothness of the exact
solution so as long as the exact
solution is smooth in principle and this
is very important because you'll see
that in practice there are formidable
difficulties in doing it in principle
we see that both these objects the
residual of the PD this object here as
well as the training error or the loss
function these can be made as small as
possible because the Exact Solutions of
these can be made as small as possible
you can estimate them so essentially
this can be this can be made as small as
possible because you can make the neural
networks in the space of neural networks
you have some closeness some
approximation to the exact solution of
the PD so in princi principle this is a
well post or a feasible problem however
in practice we don't have access to the
exact Solution that's the whole point of
pins we have to infer them through the
indirect information that is given by
the pde and to do that so we said that
there are two structural conditions that
one can use so first is what is called a
coercivity this is as I said in the last
lecture this is some sort of a stability
condition so this tells you if you
remember so this was essentially U minus
u in some form is less than or equal to
C of U U Bar U hat in this case du minus
du
hat okay this didn't even fit so never
mind okay so it tells us that if you
change the inputs to the PD in a small
manner the outputs of the PD change so
some sort of stability or this is often
called as civity and this is essential
in order once this is there I had this
little argument last time which
convinced you that if this is the case
then the total error can be bounded in
terms of the PD residual right and once
you make the PD residual small the total
error is going to be small and of course
we don't have a control on this we don't
have a handle on this we compute it with
quadrature so one can use some sort of
quadrature random sampling quasi Monte
Carlo whatever in order to sort of
estimate it in terms of the training
error so at the end of the day we are
given with an estimate which looks
something like this what does this
estimate tell us this estimate tells us
that if the training error is small and
this is a big F so this has to be small
and this guy has to be if you have
sufficient number of quadrature points
then the PD residual itself is going to
be small and once the PD residual is
small if the PD is cive or has the
stability properties you can leverage
them in order to make the total error
small so this is I keep on repeating
that there are many sort of uh links in
this chain right so one link in case
that you should have sufficient number
of quadrature points and that depends on
the dimension that depends on the
smoothness of the function and so on and
so forth then you should have
sufficiently low training error and
later on after the break today we are
going to see whether this can be done or
not and finally you should have some
nice properties of the PD that allow you
to make this small residual into a small
error okay so this is sort of the basic
algorithm and what we are going to do in
the first part of the lecture today is
to work out some simple examples to see
whether this is true or not and already
you'll see that this gives us a lot of
insight into what is going on okay so
this is where we are and this is where
we are going to start with today are
there any questions from within the
room no feel free to ask or people on
Zoom if you have any questions uh chime
in you can just ask it through the chat
function the chat button okay if not
let's do some concrete examples and I
picked up some examples which are sort
of illustr in the breadth and depth of
PDs the first example is what is called
cogora of PDs they they look complicated
but they are actually not that
complicated so the point about kogoro
pdes is that they include the heat
equation so this is of course what you
have already seen so the heat equation
is essentially UT is equal to laian of U
so this is the simplest and let's see
why this equation is uh related to this
equation here so all that you have to do
is to take the transport term so this is
what is called the drift often this if
this is equal to zero then this term of
course vanishes and if these guys are
just identity this is um what is called
the volatility sometimes so these these
objects are identity then you'll just
get the trace of the hen and you get
back the heat equation so this is the
simplest example of a Time dependent PD
that there is and it models various
things diffusions mixing BR motion and
whatnot and then the reason why we wrote
it in this elaborate form is because in
option pricing so this comes from
Finance so what you do is you have a
very famous PD that governs the prices
of options European options and this is
called a black schs equation uh many of
you might have heard it it's a black shs
equation and the black schs equation uh
is also in this form it is a particular
example of this so all that you do in
this particular case is that uh so the
drift here this is aine so this is
simply U of mu of XJ mu is often called
the interest rate right so this depends
on what the central banks or the banks
are going to give you in terms of money
so that is just a very simple term here
and then these objects here these
so-called correlations these are given
in terms of what is called volatilities
and you can see that there is some terms
which are looking here so this is also a
fairly simple
term let's wait for the ambulance to go
yeah so often in a basic PD or a basic
engineering class you have seen the heat
equation you have probably also seen the
black shs equation these are all in this
very general form okay but essentially
what you can think of them is some
generalization of the heat equation okay
with some some additional terms thrown
in which which are let's say mild manner
in fact you can you can transform one
into the other but uh the main point
somehow in these problems often is the
heat equation is very easy to solve you
can use a finite difference scheme and
as I showed you few lectures ago and you
get a very accurate solution so what's
the caveat the caveat is that these
equations particularly the black schs
equation this can be very high
dimensional because D is the number of
so this the number of um stocks
essentially your
bonds so if in your portfolio have 100
stocks this is going to be 100
dimensional equation okay so now this
equation is sort of a prototypical PD
and let us see what happens in this
equation are these structural condition
fulfilled right so let's try to walk you
through that I'm not going to give any
detailed proofs but just give you some
nice arguments so again this was done a
few years ago and the idea is that first
you have to argue and remember that here
the dimension is the key issue right
because you want to solve this problem
in 100
Dimensions if possible even in a
thousand Dimensions people can people
can do it okay so what's the idea the
idea is that if you take a pin
um of course you have to take the tan H
activation function you can take some
other activation function like sigmoid
this will also work so main point is
that what you can see is that the size
of the neural network this is going to
not depend because of course you can get
a low accuracy if the size of your
neural network grows exponentially but
in this particular case that's the whole
point that you don't have an exponential
growth so this Alpha here is polinomial
is actually depending on for the heat
equation this is even linear or
quadratic okay so the details are not
important here but the take-home message
is that by using some deep math what you
can argue is that at least in principle
there exists neural networks which are
going to approximate it to sufficient
accuracy independent or polinomial in
the in the dimension and not
exponentially that's why we claim that
this overcome the curse of
dimensionality Okay so in principle
whether you do it in practice or not is
uh going to be different now remember
that our objective is not to show this
in principal results but in practice
results and what are these in practice
results that somehow from the structural
properties of the pde you should be able
to read out that if I make a small
residual I get a small um let's say I
get a small solution or a small error
and this is based on the stability of
the PD and uh this requires a small
argument that I'm going to show you in a
very very quickly because it's so easy
so let me just do this let's take the
onedimensional heat equation okay so you
have UT is equal to uxx this is the heat
equation for the time being I'm assuming
that there are some initial conditions U
at x0 is U U Bar of
X and um U at um okay so this is uh and
some zero boundary conditions so U at 0
= to UU at 1 = Z for all times okay for
all so now remember that the whole point
is stability so let me try to illustrate
that I'll take a different solution U
now UB bar was a bad idea but let's
change that to U hat them U hat of T is
equal to U hat XX plus some let's say
residual R right so this is for instance
what comes out if you do a neural
network and let's say for simpl it that
it has the same initial conditions U hat
of
x0 is equal to U of X and the same
boundary conditions so the only
fluctuation so you match the initial and
boundary conditions the only fluctuation
is that the pointwise residual is no
longer zero now all that you do is that
you take the difference W which is U
minus U hat and then all that you do is
if you sub subtract one from the other
you take this then very easy to see the
W T is equal to
wxx -
R okay something like that I could have
also flipped the signs a little so let's
see if I can erase
it just because I like a plus here okay
it doesn't really matter right so now we
have this equation and then from this we
have to infer that if the r is small the
difference W is going to be small right
how do you do that that's fair simple
and of course w at um x0 is Zer that is
because the initial conditions agree and
W at 0 equals w at 1 which is equal to Z
this is because the boundary conditions
agree so only fluctuation the only
perturbation between the two equations
is given by this term R and the argument
that we're trying to make is that if R
is small then W is going to be small
because this R is the PD residual W is
the error between the exact solution and
the approximate solution let's say the
pin in this particular case and then we
just we can very easily argue this this
is just a oneline argument so that's why
I write it so all that I do is I
multiply uh let me take black so
wwt plus is equal to W
wxx + r w this is I just multiply it
then I know that this is nothing but DT
w^2 / 2 is equal to w w
XX plus r w nothing nothing fancy and
this is nothing but less than or equal
to
wwxx plus I use the inequality a is less
than a s /
2+ b s two and then you have R 2 2 + w^
2/ 2 okay so this is straight forward
and then I
integrate so because at the end of the
day the errors integral so if I
integrate from 0 to 1 this is also very
straightforward w^ 2 2 DX is less than
or equal to integration does not change
anything W
wxx + 0 to 1 half R 2 DX + half 0 1 W 2
of
DX so now it's very simple as you can
see this is a derivative in time and
then integral is over space right so you
can just flip
them 0 to 1 w^ 2/ 2 DX is less than or
equal to now here I'll do something
interesting a very very simple trick all
of you should be able to know this so I
have the product of two functions here
so I can use integration by
parts this is in one Dimensions so
everyone knows what integration by paths
is so if you take it then you have minus
0 to 1 of WX so you throw a derivative
on to W so it's WX squ DX and the
boundary terms are going to vanish can
anyone say why the boundary terms are
going to vanish because the boundary
conditions themselves are zero if you
remember boundary conditions themselves
oh
sorry boundary conditions themselves are
zero so the boundary terms are going to
vanish so once you have this then you
are almost done because you have half R
2 DX +
half W 2 okay so now the half can be
cancelled this quantity here is always
going to be a negative quantity because
so this entire thing is
negative right because this is a
positive quantity it's a square so this
will imply that d/ DT of w² of DX is
less than or equal to w² DX + r² of
DX okay so this is a very
straightforward and then many of you
have seen from basic is that we could
use something like what is called a
grown walls
inequality uh let me add so this will
imply I write it on the other page so
let's add a
page this is just some rough work so
what did we have so we have d/
DT of w² of d X is less than or equal to
w^2 DX
+ r
2 DX and then you have something called
the grown walls
inequality it's just telling that
nothing grows faster than an exponential
essentially and this will tell us
that w^ 2 at
T of DX will be less than or equal to
essentially 0 to
t 0 to 1 r² of XT DX
DT because the initial conditions also
agree so the initial conditions vanish
and you're just left with this forcing
term so as a consequence you can see
that this if this quantity here if the
residual can be made small then
automatically the error can be
made right so this is all that is there
you can see that we have used we have
lever the stability of the PD the
details of the proof are not important
because it's it's essentially a few
lines right but essentially we have
leverage the stability of the PD and we
have concluded that if you have a small
residual then you can have a small total
error okay and this is precisely the
point that is butress through this
argument here as you can see sorry this
argument here which says exactly the
same thing that of course now there are
initial conditions boundary conditions
and so on and so forth and because of
the boundary conditions you will have a
square root here rather than a square
but essentially the argument is exactly
the same so if the residuals are going
to be small with a constant which is
independent of the solution this is a
linear pde you get that the total error
is going to be controlled okay so this
is uh this a simple argument now you can
argue why do I need to learn about this
well because it's important right
otherwise how else will you conclude
that the error is going to be small so
here you Leverage the stability of the
PD later on in a few minutes you'll see
that there are some PDS which don't have
this property and then things get ify
okay the last point so this can be done
so as you can see this part is over this
can be done stability implies small
error but what about the quad bounds so
because of the very high dimension you
can only use random sampling nothing
else works okay so you can use random
sampling
and then there are some random sampling
essentially means that you use what is
called the central limit theorem so
essentially you can show that the PD
residual is given in terms of the
training error and the total number of
quadrature points but it's square root
of n okay so this is there is a
logarithmic correction because things
are correlated but there is a
logarithmic correction and this is
essentially independent of dimension
so now it's uh independent of Dimension
it is always going to be square root of
n or with a correction because there's a
log on top but you know that any power
grows faster than a log so of course
these things Decay as n decays so what
have we show so we have been able to
show that for this particular class of
PDs albe very special class of PDs with
wide applications you have that because
of the stability of the PD small
residuals imply small errors and because
of Monte Caro if you take sufficient
number of points independent of the
dimension by the way this estimate was
also independent of the dimension so all
this is independent of the dimension as
long as you have small training errors
which is a big if then the total error
is going to be small and this is also
borne out through actual estimates
numerical experiments let me show you
this example so this is in 1D but it's
already telling you what's going on so
in 1D we can explicitly compute some of
these upper bounds so this is the bound
that we just had derived and you can see
that as the number of quadrature points
uh increases it's not a lot of qu points
it's between 100 and th000 points so
this quantity decays and as a
consequence you see that the total eror
in red it also decays till it saturates
you know at the end it has to saturate
so they are sort of following each other
as expected however the total error is
much smaller than the bound the bound is
is a very let's say pessimistic upper
bound you can see that this is how many
orders of magnitude like three orders of
magnitude difference between them so
they have the same qualitative
information but quantitatively you
cannot use this bound to say how small
the error is going to be it's
pessimistic but it's nevertheless it
tells you something tells you that the
errors can be made small and this is
also very interesting because uh this is
the training
error okay and this is the total error
and it says you that as this training
error becomes smaller the this is a log
log plot okay so here's a log here's a
log so as you can see that the as the
training error is small the total error
is going to be small which is consistent
with this inequality uh sometimes the
training error can be large and the
total error can be small but never the
other way around it cannot happen that
the training error is small and the
total error is large so this this is
some practical significance right it
tells us that at the time of training a
pen we can observe that the error is is
going to be small the training error
because this we just compute from the
loss function and then we know that the
total error is going to be small so that
gives us some confidence on that okay
our training process has worked now we
can use this okay and what is also very
interesting is that uh estimate tells us
that it's it goes like a square root of
the training error and it's indeed true
because as you can see there are six
orders here in the training era and
there are approximately three orders in
the in the total
so as expected it also behaves like a
square root so in that sense
quantitatively the theory is quite tight
but because there is uh this no curse of
dimensionality this also allows us in
practice okay these were my rough
calculations this allows us in practice
to do computations up to people have
done now up to a million Dimensions but
at least we could do easily up to 100
Dimensions without any problems and you
can see that for the heat heat equation
itself the error increased as as you
would expect remember that there was a
polinomial not exponential increase
polinomial increase but it was really
polinomial it was even linear so between
20 dimensions and 100 dimensions for the
same compute time the error increased by
a factor of I don't know four right so
this is less than even a linear increase
so this is consistent this was for the
heat equation and for the black schs
equation the the one from the option
pricing it was similar so for in
distance between 20 dimensions and 100
dimensions and this is roughly I don't
remember now but let's say 1 hour of
training so we fix the compute and then
we see how the how the error scaled and
these are the numbers that you can see
so here even between 20 and H Dimensions
five times increase there only increased
by a factor of two so it's even
sublinear in some sense and similarly
you could do hon this is another of
these equations also used in option
pricing and another different uh
coefficients different uh formulas but
essentially the same story again you can
go without much of an increase in error
it does increase but very very mildly so
this tells us that this is phenomenal
right we can solve a 100 dimensional PD
within an hour of training to one 1%
1.5% 2% at so that's that's somehow very
very satisfactory there are caveats
which you'll see see in a bit but at
least for these particular problems uh
things seem to work uh let's do a little
bit more of this this is a very
interesting PD another example that I
wanted to give with not a lot of details
uh this is radiative transfer so for
instance when the energy comes from the
sun it is essentially radiation uh it's
also very important in climate and so on
and so forth also in engineering because
there are many many processes where
radiation plays a big role so
essentially there is a BD some of you
have seen this probably but but it's
it's a very special kind of a PD let me
walk you through so this the quantity of
Interest U is what is called the
radiative intensity okay this somehow
measures the total amount of radiation
at each point and in time and there is a
master equation which CS
this it seems rather complicated but it
is not so this is of course the time
derivative c as you can imagine is a
speed of light okay because radiation is
light essentially right so it travels
very fast so essentially this is a very
very small term because 1 / C is a very
very small quantity so essentially in
most applications that we are interested
on Earth this term can be essentially
neglected the whole term can be
neglected even though in astrophysics
like when you have exploding Supernova
the speed at which these things happen
is comparable to the speed of light so
you can't can't ignore it now this
quantity now when radiation comes you
can compute the angle so this is what is
called the angle
okay and then these are this is
essentially
absorption
absorption the details are not important
here so as you can see that this is a
first order derivative here and there is
a source term here and there is a
non-local term so this is what is called
scattering because radiation is
scattered different uh Rays come and
they get scattered this is scattering
and this is measured in terms of um this
this complicated formula which tells us
that you take all the angles together
and you integrate the scattering
coefficient and finally there are some
Source terms right so how many
dimensions are there so this U is a
function of
time in general but in many many cases
you can ignore time it's a function of
space space is usually three-dimensional
it's a function of angle so when you are
looking at three dimensional space you
have two angles so that's two dimensions
and this new is a frequency because
radiation happens at different
frequencies so it's a function of
frequency so this is one dimension two
dimensions three dimensions one
dimension so in the most General case
it's a seven dimensional prop and seven
dimensions it's uh just imagine even if
you take 10 grid points in each
Dimension then 10 the^ 7 is a very very
high number and essentially it is
difficult to store that kind of well in
the modern computers you can barely
store them but if you 10 10 points is
not going to give you any kind of
accuracy so you would need 100 points
and then you're out right so you you
cannot solve this problem by using
traditional finite element methods and
so on and there's an entire subject of
radiative numerical radiative transfer
that tries to do that so but pins as I
said the good thing about them is that
they have this Dimension independent
property you never have to generate a
grid you can just use random points and
in this particular case we don't use
random points we use something called
quasi random points but that's that's
not a not a big deal similar estimates
can be derived exactly because it's a
linear equation so it has exactly the
same kind of uh features properties as
the heat equation in in some limit it is
in fact the heat equation so one can one
can use that as an argument but let me
show you the examples here right so we
solved this problem in also in seven
dimensions in the paper but essentially
you look at either two Dimensions or six
dimensions so two Dimensions means one
space Dimension and one angle Six
Dimensions means three space two angles
and one frequency so this is the this is
the harder problem and of course we
fixed the network size so the complexity
is the same but we changed the the
training time is the same because uh we
we just fixed it and then we saw how the
error develops and of course there is
more error when you go from two
Dimensions to Six Dimensions but
nevertheless even for a six dimensional
problem which is visualized here using
some three-dimensional quantity it's
called the radiative flux you can see
that the error is only 2% it took 1 hour
in a finite element code that I had for
many many years this took maybe 15 days
you know to get similar kind of Errors
so it took only one hour maybe in modern
computers this will take 7 Days uh but
it's there are two orders of magnitude
here and you can get 2% ER so again this
is there is in principle mathematical
guarantee which is also reflected in the
practice so High dimensional problems
that's that's that's good for the that's
good for this kind of this kind of
constructions good so let me give you
another example now let's try to explore
some of the negatives not just the
positives right so of course this is the
fundamental equations of fluid dynamics
we'll come again and again to these
equations this is the n Navia Stokes
equations and for those who don't know
what these terms are so U is a velocity
so this is a
velocity this is two or three
dimensional it's the
vector uh then p is the
pressure it's a Scala so essentially you
have um in three dimensions you have
four quantities here three components of
the Velocity one component of the
pressure uh new is what is called the
viscosity it's a very small number
because even for water maybe it's not
very small for the hair gel or something
like that but uh it's a It's relatively
large for a hair gel because it's very
discuss but for water this is like 10 ^-
7 for air it is like 10^ -5 so this is a
very very small number okay so you can
in many practical cases ignore this term
so three equations uh three four
variables and four equations because
these are three equations here and the
Divergence because the flow is
incompressible the Divergence is going
to be zero so there are four equations
and four four unknowns all of fluid
dynamics relies on this fundamental
equation and we'll revisit it again
again and again and again so in
principle you can solve it with finite
elements finite differences finite
volumes but you can also solve it with
pins and then the thing is can we go
through this entire theoretical argument
it turns out yes because if you remember
that as long as the solutions are
smooth by the way this is what is in
general unknown and in fact some of you
might know that this is one of these
million dollar problems that was posed
at the turn of the Millennium that if
you can show mathematically that the
solutions syst smooth you get a million
dollars but people believe that the
solutions are in some sense smooth
nevertheless if they are smooth and this
is the smooth in the sense that the K
derivative is going to be square
integrable then the pin has a certain
size and the error can be made as small
as possible because but just by taking
larger and larger neural networks you
can get a small error okay so in
principle but remember that in practice
we have to argue that the total error
this guy here is related to the
residuals so these are the residuals for
the different objects here and this can
be done this has been done in this paper
for instance but the point is that uh
the constant here now remember that in
our arguments we never bothered about
the constants because they were linear
problems mostly but in general you
cannot do that the constants have to
depend on the PD as well as on the
neural network so here the constant
depends on where is it and this is a
important caveat so this quantity here
is a curl of the Velocity field some of
you might recognize it as a
verticity and the whole point about flow
fluid fluid flows in three dimensions is
the voity can have very complex Behavior
so voity in principle can be large so if
the vity is larger and larger then this
estimate becomes more and more useless
because even though these quantities can
be made small this is still large right
and in fact you can use uh so this is an
important aavia so this for nonlinear
PDS it depends a little bit on the
property of the PDS and if you take this
example where the verticity is like this
is actually the vortex which is being
aded at most this is like order of three
so this is not not so difficult and this
is the ground truth this is what the pin
gives you these are fairly good
approximations the error is already less
than 1% um means this is 1% so the error
is less than 1% and the bound that we
prove is very close to the so this is
sort of comparable to each other but in
this problem the verticity is of the
order of one okay it's not not that
large as long as the training error can
be made small the total error is going
to be small okay so this is uh sort of
the main main point here that if the
verticity becomes large you might not be
able to do a good approximation and this
is also borne out because now we try to
increase the verticity uh quite a bit uh
earlier the verticity was large in the
sense that it was concentrated in this
little Vortex but now you have larger
and larger vertices so as you can see
this goes all the way from um five to
minus5 so these these vertices here and
these vertices here and they're also
more sort of spread out in some sense
and you can see that uh as as the time
progresses there is more and more
verticity which is being generated and
the quality of the approximation suffers
right so if you focus on the picture
here in the beginning this was less
blurred than this guy but here for
instance these vortices are very sharp
and this is completely
blurred okay so this tells us ahuh there
is a caveat here that if you have a very
complex solution with lots of verticity
for this particular case your
approximation is not going to be good
and in fact that is true if you take a
more complex flow so this is fairly
simple flows which already Illustrated
the idea but if you take a more complex
flow like if you have a cylinder and you
have flow past the cylinder then there
is a number called the renals number
which tells you how complex the flow is
and in fact there is no pin which can do
more than an enal number of 500 the for
water the Ral number is 10 ^ 7 so 100
million between 10 million and 100
million so you are you're far off and
there is a there is a mathematical or
there is a good reason for that and the
reason is that in this case the
solutions to the P themselves are fairly
complicated so somehow this is something
that that one one should one should
always remember instead of blindly
applying these methods uh this is
another example which tells you some of
the caveats that are there and let me
explain it quickly and then we go into
the break so the this is the viscus
burgers
equation
so it has both transport so this is
nonlinear transport this
term and it is diffusion so this term is
diffusion it is like the heat equation
right so if you did not have this
quantity here this would be just a heat
equation but the whole point of
Transport is that it forces things
nonlinear transport so some things move
faster than some other things so things
get compressed in some sense this speak
measures compression whereas diffusion
does the opposite it something is
compressed it takes it out right so this
is the this the basic idea now you can
do the same arguments as before you can
get an estimate on the total error which
behaves on the training error which
behaves on the number of points and
which depends on these constants and
these constants just like in the Navia
Stokes case they depend on the gradient
of the
velocity and the point is that the
gradient of the Velocity we know some
estimate on it we know we can measure it
in some sense we can estimated and the
gradient of the Velocity unlike the
verticity the gradient of the Velocity
we know that it behaves like 1 / square
root of this new that which measures the
strength of the diffusion so if new is
one this is order of 1 but if new is 10
^ 8 then or minus 8 then this is 10 ^ 4
it's it's it's a large number so in
Principle as new goes to zero you could
have some blow up of the solution or of
the approximation and I don't know if
you can see it but you actually see it
in practice so if you take new to be a
small number 10 the^ minus 3 you can go
all the way to 10 uh to zero or 10^
minus 8 for that matter you can see when
it is 10^ minus 3 the square root of
that is still a manageable number and
there is a very good approximation to
the exact solution but as soon as it is
10^ minus 8 or zero this really blows up
as you can see here the the quantity
really blows up so the pins in this
formulation they cannot cannot
approximate this solution you see that
there is a total failure here and just
to further sort of justify our
considerations if there is there is
another mode where the nonlinearity
causes what is called a raction means
instead of a compression in that case
the derivative doesn't blow up and pins
can do a very very good approximation
whether no is 10^ minus 3 or zero you
can see that the error actually
decreases or is is reasonably small so
this is more or less constant error here
on the other hand it blows up right so
this tells us that one has to be very
very careful when you use spins if the
solutions become complicated like for
instance the gradients grow or it
becomes more vertical or helical as one
could use then the solutions themselves
are so behaved that it gets reflected in
the errors of the pits okay so this is
an important caveat of course there are
some Alternatives but uh this is not the
time and place to do it okay so let me
just give you a very quick summary and
then after the break we will uh we will
we'll sort of take it up so essentially
the point is that for a generic PD let's
uh take this guy here for Pins we has
more or less some good theory some
rigorous good insight and a rigorous
error estimate which morally goes like
this the difference between the ground
truth and the best approximation that we
can do depends on three things it
depends on the number of quadri points
this is always something that we can
make small for instance even independent
of Dimension if this is random points so
this is a good thing this is this is a
good term but there are two terms here
that could be problematic first one is
this one so depending on the PD this
term can be large right and as you saw
this can lead to some failure modes
because if the solution is more vertical
if there are more complicated things
happening then you might have a failure
and the final term that we have not yet
done anything about is the training
error so this is still a question right
so this term depends on the pte this
this one here but uh if you look at the
training error this is still a question
mark at the moment I have even said that
it's a black box right and after the
break all that we know is from these
General considerations that the global
minimum and this is an important point
that there a global minimum is as small
as you want depending on the size of the
size of the M
Network so there is a global minimum
which is going to be smaller but can we
ever reach that because remember that
the end of the day even for the smallest
networks that we saw so I don't remember
let's take one of the concrete examples
here right so the network size is that
there are eight layers here eight layers
20 neurons in each layer so the number
of weights and biases is roughly 400 per
per lay in some sense we have eight
layers so it's uh let's say 4,000
roughly speaking because there are also
some output layers and so on so it's
4,000 small Network fairly small network
but you can see that uh it's still a
4,000 dimensional problem right so in
these 4,000 Dimensions you have to
optimize a loss function and the
question is there is a global minimum
somewhere which is going to be small but
we have to start somewhere which as Ben
has already taught you and you saw in
the tutorials we essentially start
randomly right so we start the random we
initialize things randomly can we ever
reach the global minimum because
everything relies on that because unless
until we reach a small or even a good
local minimum we don't have to reach a
global minimum if we reach a good local
minimum then as long as the PD is nice
this error is going to be small and we
are in business right and this is what
we saw for many many problems that we
could reach a good local minimum for
instance otherwise how would we get 2%
error and also you saw this for these
problems here that the training error
could be made fairly small in fact even
100 Dimensions you would have training
errors like 10 ^ minus 3 right so in
those problems you could you could see
that but can this be done in general so
this is still a challenge and after the
break let's take a break now um we we
yes
have yeah they depends on the rals
number because um you can also have
lamina flows for very high rals numbers
but uh they they they they do struggle
they can struggle but they are much
better at lamina flow than a turbulent
flow so there is there is that
possibility okay so let's uh gather here
at quarter past and then we we resume
the lecture so I should just pause the
record
yeah also to everyone on Zoom we are
restarting now so as I said before the
break so the key point is um essentially
I was telling one of one of your
classmates during the break that for
many many different pdes of course this
term that I'm highlighting here could be
problematic but for many other pdes
particularly for linear PD this term is
very mild means it does not even depend
on you so this let's say is a imprint of
nonlinearity this is only true for
nonlinear
PDS if it's a linear PD it's independent
of you and you here so in that case as
long as we can train well and if you
have sufficient number of photage points
we should be okay so but as I said
before the break so the training error
is a black box and let us try to open
let's see if this black box can be open
and you'll see that at least we can open
it a little not not entirely otherwise
somehow the machine learning problem
would be solved Which is far from the
case so let us see let's try to unpack
the Black Box a little okay and and it's
based on a theoretical framework that
was proposed very recently by some of us
here so this is the paper maybe the
paper can be uploaded if those who want
to want to look at it I'll just give you
a very very let's say easy version of it
perhaps even a dumb version of it just
so that we don't get lost in the details
right so essentially what is uh the
problem of pins or physics in form
training boiling down to so the problem
is that you have of course a loss
function and I have taken a very
remember that our PD is Du equal to F
this is always the case so our loss
function is given by just L2 for
Simplicity because then it's easier to
do some of the calculations so you have
this is the loss function and you have
to minimize this loss right so you have
a neural network U which is dependent on
X in this case X can be both space and
time is dependent on parameters Theta
and you need to select these parameters
Theta right so to select these
parameters Theta what we use is gradient
descent stochastic gradient descent adom
bfgs whatever but there are all in some
sense some variations some more
efficient variations of grent and gr
descent is a very very simple algorithm
which tells us that you stand at a point
you look where this is what we do if you
have to go down you look where there is
a negative gradient and you just walk in
the direction of the negative gradient
and hopefully you'll find the the
minimum uh in general it can if it's a
convex function it'll be the global
minimum but these functions are far from
convex I think Ben showed you some of
the Lost Landscapes of these functions
and these are lots of Hills and Valleys
but hopefully we can find a good local
minimum and gradient descent has some
other very nice properties that uh
structural properties which make it
useful in the context of machine
learning and also this this algorithm
can be done in any Dimensions so whether
it is 4,000 Dimensions like the pin that
I showed you or the largest llms that
are out there which are closing towards
the trillion Dimensions the the
principle is exactly the same so you
have to compute the gradient with
respect to the loss and you have to move
in the direction of the negative
gradient right so this is the algorithm
so the itate at k + 1 depends on the
itate at K and the gradient at the
iterated K okay that's that's all with
some learning rate and this learning
rate is usually typically is small right
okay so now we need to understand and
remember that there's a big difference
between this problem and the traditional
supervised learning which is what you
would use for instance to train an llm
with in traditional supervised learning
the loss function here would be some
integral of U minus some U Theta minus
some ground root U Bar some labels right
but in this case we don't have that we
don't have any labels so we have to
infer everything from the PD which is
given here and you'll see that that
leads to tremendous differences in the
way we learn and let me try to explain a
little me as I said I will have to Dum
it down because I don't have the time
for all the details if you're interested
you can talk to me later or you can read
the paper so the first thing we do is
that instead of working with the
parameters so the Theta the weights and
biases we look at what happens to the
function during training because after
all at the end of the day we have a
neural network and we want to see how
this neural network behaves behaves
during training how it is updated what
are the Dynamics of the neural network
so this you can say is NN
Dynamics during
training okay so let's do let's start at
a point Theta 0 so of course Theta 0 is
where we start The Descent and then
let's say that at least we're close to
the Theta Z then we can do a Tor
expansion in fact whether we are close
or far we can always do a Tor expansion
so we do a tailor expansion in Theta so
Theta K is the value of theta 0 plus the
gradient of course so the gradient with
respect to Theta remember that the
gradient with respect to Theta is an
important quantity because it also comes
in the loss function then the distance
from the iterate so this is the distance
from the iterate and then the remainder
term and the remainder term depends on
the second derivative so it depends on
the HM so HK is nothing but the second
derivative so this is
the gradient squared of with respect to
Theta of U so this this is the hen of
the function so this is the quadratic
term and of course you evaluate it using
the mean value theorem so that this is
an exact inequality right this is an
exact identity so in principle you can
rewrite gradient descent just by
reordering so this is a long calculation
but essentially you can rewrite it in
the following way so this is around
initialization so maybe perhaps I
highlight this a little bit so what
happens is that around initialization so
this is essentially doing some algebra
you get three kinds of terms so one is
so in all these terms what plays a big
role as you can imagine is this um pis
so this is sort of the tangent
directions so you take U the function
itself and uh what is the gradient with
respect to Theta this tells you how the
function what is the tangent Direction
at a certain point right so these are
the tangent directions sometimes they
constitute what is called the neural
tangent kernel you'll see that in the
second slide but essentially these are
the tangent directions this is what is
called a gr Matrix this is very
intuitive why this happens because all
that we have to do is we have to compute
the differential operator apply so
remember that I take this Thea expansion
and I just plug it in right because this
will tell me what happens at the L or
the Kate and when I plug it in there is
some term which is dependent on Theta 0
doesn't change during training then
there is some quadratic term that we
call as a remainder term here this we
are not going to unpack but the linear
term is where the action is so in this
linear term here you can see that some
of these terms are going to come but
essentially what it tells you is that
the it rate depends on some quadratic
terms remainder terms it depends on
Theta K which is a current value and
this is where this gram Matrix comes in
and it depends on Theta 0 because you're
starting at Theta 0 you're doing a DA
expansion so this kind of a what is
called a simplified gradient descent I
think I call it as a simplifi grent
descent so this is an exact
characterization we have just used dat
expansions and we have sort of unpacked
or unrolled the different terms okay the
details are not important here they they
they just come from the come from the
structure the algebraic structure of the
problem but is important is to remember
that this is a sort of a gram Matrix
this is a structure of a matrix okay
okay uh now as long as this error term
is small and I will tell you exactly
when this error term is small then
gradient descent is what approximated by
what people can sometimes call as
simplified gradient descent or some
other people call it as lazy gradient
descent there are different names to it
it just tells you that at least locally
when you're not far then gradient
descent can be done much more simply so
in the sense that it depends on Theta k
uh in terms of this Matrix you can say
this amplification factor and in terms
of what happens at Theta 0 okay so what
happens Theta K you make a small
increment and you stay close to Theta 0
and the smallness of these terms so this
Epsilon so essentially this is a
linearization assumption right because
I'm saying that this quantity is small
now this quantity measures the second
derivative the hn if the hn is going to
be small the function has to be
approximately linear so think of if it
is a linearization assumption it doesn't
mean that it is always satisfied during
um neural network training but at least
near initialization this is typically
satisfied and that is what is called the
ntk or the neural tangent kernel
regime so this is called the neural
tangent again the details are not
important here all that you can think of
is that we are starting training we are
moving a little bit along some small
directions so essentially the phase is
going to be linear so under these
assumptions you can actually compute
exactly whether there will be
convergence or not so let's say that you
are close to a local minimum how fast
you converge so in that particular case
this is a very simple Matrix equation so
you can just do some algebra and you get
this expression here and this expression
tells us that the speed of convergence
okay there is Convergence because this
uh is this quantities are less than one
in some sense this condition number is
always greater than one so this quantity
is less than one but depending on how
close this is to one you will have
different rates of convergence for
instance if it is a very very small
number then or it's very close to one
then you'll have very fast convergence
if it is a relatively far away from one
then it will have very very slow
convergence so this is this is the the
point right and the number of steps that
you require to get an error of Delta is
logarithmic in Delta as you would expect
so you have some sort of exponential
convergence but there is this Factor
here K of this Matrix a and this K from
those who know some numerical analysis
this is what is called the condition
number okay so remember that this is a
matrix this is a matrix which takes this
tangent directions uh this can be
explicitly computed in some cases it
computes the differential operator on
these tangent directions takes an inner
product of them and then essentially
this uh gives you the conditioning of
this problem so at least near
linearization if or near a local minimum
if you initialize near local minimum all
that it tells us that you can do it fast
or slow depending on how well this
problem is conditioned so your training
can be expensive or cheap if this
condition number for instance if this
condition number is very close to one
let's say that this is very close to one
the C is like one so this quantity here
is very very close to zero which means
that it goes the number of steps is
going to be very very small let's say
this is close to one so it's essentially
exponential but if this condition number
is a th then you are in problem right
because uh then this is going to be
0.001 or the number of steps is at least
going to be off the order of a th so the
it gets it gets very very expensive the
good thing about this formulation is
under certain assumptions which one can
argue and you'll see some examples of
that in a bit
you can quantify how quickly we can
converge to local minim okay and the
answer is that it completely depends on
the condition number of this gram of
this Matrix this of this quantity which
looks a bit bit obscure here at first
site but actually this Matrix is not
completely upscu it has a very
interesting um let's say manifestation
or very interesting interpretation
because it is related to the
differential operator so this is the
differential operator Ator just think
this could be the laian this could be
the heat equation this could be the wave
equation whatever this is the this is
the sort of family of the of this
differential operator and then in
function analysis in pdes and so on
there is an object which is called the
her Mission Square it is like applying
this differential operator twice okay
but except that this D star here is what
is called the adjoint of a differential
operator it's just the generalization of
Matrix so remember that if you have a
matrix you know what is a transpose of a
matrix similarly if you think of an
Operator Operator is nothing but an
infinite dimensional Matrix then the
adjoint is nothing but a suitable
version of the transpose I I don't have
to Define it I'll give you some examples
and then you'll see what this operator
is going to be okay so then you
introduce this operator which is given
by this calligraphic a and this is
called the Herm Mission squar and it
turns out that this Matrix here this
gram Matrix uh which is written here
which tells you everything about the
training at least near initialization
this is related to this Herm Mission
squar okay in fact it's it's a very
simple calculation that it is related to
the sumission squar there is some
because this is this guy is a matrix so
this is if you remember this is the gram
Matrix gram Matrix or graman as some
people call it this is the Herm mission
squar of course this is a operator this
is a matrix so you know to pull it down
from infinite Dimensions to finite
Dimensions we use some some kernel
functions but that that's that's
essentially a detail so all that you
have to think of is that my training
depends on the condition number of a
matrix which is morally equivalent to
morally the same as the condition number
of an operator and this operator is not
the differential operator itself because
that is that okay if it was a
differential operator it is the at it's
ad joint applied to the differential
operator or what is called the her
Mission Square so let me give you some
examples so the simplest example is if
you take the POS equation then D is the
minus minus right but unfortunately the
well not unfortunately but in this
particular case minus llin is a self
adjoint operator so it's ad jointed
itself so you apply essentially minus
lashan to the minus llan and you end up
clearly with a fourth order operator
this is called The Bash okay so this
operator is called the
bashin and it sort of it comes up in
elasticity equations those who have seen
structural Dynamics structural mechanics
might have known this so This measures
somehow so the laian essentially the
second derivative measures the curvature
but now this measures higher geometrical
quantities in some sense so this is the
bash and this makes it uh this makes the
condition number very very bad because
okay this is very easy so if you take a
square or if you take 0 to one okay so
let me just give you a little bit of
facts here and you take the minus plus
so the I values of this because that's
what we are looking for the I values of
the minus llan are given by essentially
k y^ 2 okay so this is this is roughly
the I values which means that the
scaling between the minimum k K can be
from 0 1 to K capital K the scaling
between the maximum igen value and the
minimum igen value grows like K squ
quadratic okay so the condition number
is not very nice but at least it is
going to be quadratic and we could have
managed if that was the case but for the
bashian the condition number the igen
values of the bashian and this is sort
of the problem you can easily calculate
it uh it's not hard this scales as a
fourth power as you can imagine so now
the condition number grows like a by
quadratic right so instead of a
quadratic it's a by quadratic so you can
just imagine that if my problem has four
modes let's say now K to the^ 4 the^ 4
is a very large quantity right it is
256 and if the condition number is
already 256 1 - 1/ 256 is a relatively
large quantity in in some sense it's and
then the convergence is accordingly slow
you need at least 256 steps but this is
a very very rude rough calculation but
if you remember I think Ben showed you
some examples where the problem has
oscillatory structure it has like I
don't know 10 moles then you're finished
because uh 10 ^ 4 is 10,000 so you need
10,000 steps of gradient descent this is
a very ballpark calculation but you need
10,000 steps of gradient descent to be
anywhere close right and this is this is
not very satisfactory so this is a very
negative thing and this tells you that
first of all this can be very high and
this is the very nature of the Beast
that the high order derivatives are
worse condition than low order
derivatives and because we are forcing
the differential operator your condition
number is twice in some sense that of
the differential operator and this is
the key difference because if you had
supervised learning this is if you train
with respect to labels then this D the
differential operator in that case would
simp simply be the
identity right the differential operator
would be the identity and the a would be
identity composed with identity which
would be simply
identity and there the condition number
would simply depend on the condition
number of the neural tangent Cur okay
it's not always one but it is it's a
relatively nice number here on the other
hand in addition to what would have
happened with supervised learning you
get this additional Factor here and this
additional factor which depends on the
differ operator which is endemic to all
physics inform learning this will tell
us that okay this problem is not well
conditioned in general particularly if
the number of modes in the problem are
large right because if there's only one
mode the condition number is it's just
one there's only one IG value but if
there are 10 modes for instance the
contrast between the maximum igen value
and the minimum igen value can grow very
very rapidly and this makes it hard to
learn problems which are oscillatory and
I think Ben showed you some examples of
that okay the first lesson that you
learn from this is that training physics
inform form neural networks is basted by
itself and remember that if you train it
if it's a linear problem like a wave
equation heat equation and so on you're
done but training itself is a problem
because this is where this uh this point
really comes in so you cannot work with
uh okay I I'll I'll teach you something
about preconditioning but the point is
that you cannot Direct L work with um
with training as it is so you cannot
directly work with gradient desent okay
what you have to do and this is uh
because of this ill conditioning okay so
this is a very very important point so
are there any questions also from people
on on Zoom about what constitutes the
difference between um training in
supervised learning and training in
physics and formar so math is not
important what is important here is the
concept that you are changing something
you're changing nature of the problem
and by changing the nature of the
problem you're introducing a factor an
amplification factor which depends on
the number of derivatives that you have
so if you have a third order
differential operator then you will have
sixth order derivatives and your problem
will scale up you have a question
yes this is precisely what the next
point is right so I will I will tell you
that in a second but you have sort of
guessed
my my my conclusion but on the
conclusion itself that there is a
difference is this point clear and this
is where it will come repeatedly even
when you do your exercises and you see
that oh it's not training well maybe
it's not your fault you see maybe it is
maybe it is not this is this is where
you have to you have to understand is my
problem complicated enough because that
depends on the but if you if it doesn't
train maybe there is something
intrinsically wrong with the method
itself and whatever I do it's not going
to work so you you have to make that
judgment in a particular application you
have to see whether the how many modes
are there what is the differential
operator what is the underlying physics
how well can I trade okay because once
you trade if the PDS are relatively
simple you generalize but you you do
well now how can we change this or are
we stuck with this problem of course
this is this a big big problem so are we
stuck with this problem uh not
necessarily there are some there is no
General solution because as you see
people all these things are very recent
right
so this is probably the most neatest uh
way of identifying the problem but other
people have identified similar similar
problems so let me explain at least one
General let's say procedure General
framework in which this can be corrected
which is through the concept of
preconditioning and for that I need to
add the page and write a little bit so
what is the preconditioning that your
class me just just referred to right so
if you remember gradient descent
gradient descent is Theta k + 1 my is
equal to Theta K minusa of gradient of
the loss function L of theta something
like this and the problem here comes
from the essentially the loss function
right so the point is can we do
something can we change the gradient
descent in some some sense such that uh
the condition number improves because
everything now depends on this K of a k
of a was this K of D St d right so this
is the condition number of the operator
morally although the math is a little
bit more complicated than that morally
it is just a d study so what you can do
of course is you can use a traditional
idea from numerical analysis which goes
by the name of
preconditioning the preconditioning
comes from numerical analysis it
essentially tells us that um we should
premultiply the m matx before inverting
a
matrix where the same kind of
considerations come when you do
numerical linear algebra so if you want
to invert a matrix by whatever numerical
method direct method or equative method
if the if the metrix is poorly
conditioned if there's a the aspect
ratio between its entries or its values
is very large and it's harder to go sort
of invert it so what you do is that you
multiply approximately with its inverse
invert that thing and then REM multiply
so preconditioning is a very simple idea
essentially all that you have to do is
that you have to rewrite gradi and
descent by doing let's
say um ETA of some
J of gradient of L so you modify a
gradient descent by adding this
precondition so This object here is
called a
precondition precond
conditional and morally this is of
course the math is not that easy
otherwise the problem will be solved
morally J has to be essentially a
inverse okay so it morally these things
have to be have to be a inverse so then
the sort of the condition number of j a
because J is outside a is inside so the
condition number of j a roughly will be
close to Identity close to one so this
is roughly the idea that you have to
somehow know what this a is you have to
compute this gram Matrix well you can
compute this gram matrix it's a pretty
heavy Matrix to compute where is it uh
it's a pretty heavy Matrix to compute
but if you have a operator Centric
perspective you somehow know the
operator but this is a this is a large
Matrix right because remember that let's
say we have a million
parameters then this gradient here is
Vector with a million Dimensions I'm
assuming that the output is scalar so
it's a vector with a million Dimensions
so then you can imagine that this is a
very very large Matrix so it's it's not
that easy to work with it and there are
some techniques which are slowly coming
in but I'm not not going to give belab
the point here so essentially
preconditioning is either by using the
direct form of the Matrix or by using
some knowledge about the operator all
you try to multiply a preactor precond
conditioner to your gradient descent
such that you have an approximate
inverse increase okay so this is roughly
what preconditioning is and and uh this
is what essentially it boils down to so
in fact I think Ben also mentioned this
he had this domain decomposition method
finite basis pins and so on so in the
same paper where we proposed this
theoretical framework we showed that
almost all the techniques that are there
to accelerate the training of pins
because this is acceleration right if
something takes 10,000 steps and you can
do it in 100 steps you accelerate the
training this can be viewed in terms of
preconditioning so essentially some form
or the other this idea comes in okay but
let me give you a few examples and then
we sort of close the chapter here so
this is a very simple example where
already the failure modes are very clear
so this is just a POS equation in 1D so
you have boundary conditions zero
boundary
conditions maybe it is between minus pi
and Pi but okay that's that's a minor
detail so you have the second derivative
you are given this Matrix here
and of course the solution is s of KX
right because when you differentiate s
of KX twice you get minus k s okay so s
of KX very very simple problem we don't
need a PIN to solve it we can just solve
it by hand but nevertheless what happens
if you take a pin so if you take the
condition number in fact I take a even
simpler model I don't even take a pin I
don't even take a neural network I take
a very simple model so my U Theta is
going to be what is called FIA features
parameterized FIA
features so this is like a light neural
network uh so you have
AK
s um or a l let's say sin L
pix plus PL cos L pix so these are what
are called FIA features I think Ben also
introduce them at some point and all
that you do is that these are your
training parameters maybe there is an
additional layer
so you can think of a very simple um
neural network I don't even want to use
neural networks here because you can
think of it as sign AC you can think of
it as a linear layer a sign activation
function and then an output layer so you
can think of it in those terms so if you
just take fua features me this is a very
light neural network uh then you can see
that um condition number you can
explicitly compute the condition number
in this case for this problem
you see how it grows means as K grows as
the number of f features grows this uh
thing here or L here grows this thing
Grows quadratically Right so because it
grows quadratically you need lots of and
it already becomes very very quickly 10
to the^ 8 I can't even see 10^ 8 so 100
million very very quickly with just a
few modes right uh 100 million and of
course one over 100 million is a very
very small number which means that this
whole thing goes very very slowly you
need lots and lots of steps and this is
also very clear when you do the training
because if you just take the naive
version of it which is here so these are
the number of FIA features um it doesn't
really matter the Lost function is of
the order of a thand
so so this simply doesn't pain you see
of course if you have just five modes in
the problem then it rains but if you
take uh 100 modes it simply doesn't play
so the same question happens with neural
networks they they perform even worse
the diagrams the graphs are in the paper
okay so what does this tell us that even
for a very very simple problem I don't
need to solve this using neural networks
or anything right I can solve it by hand
and I can certainly Solve IT finite
differences the this physics inform
training simply doesn't work for high
modes so has this spectral poor spectral
Behavior which is associated with the
fact that you have this
uh by quadratic growth of the and you
can see that right because this is 10
the^ two and remember that it grows like
uh by quadratically and there that's why
you get 10^ 8 of course you are you are
out so this completely matches the
theory in this case preconditioning
works very well because you know what
you have to divide so you just have to
divide with L squ because you know how
much it grows so l s here and because
there is a square so you get L the^ 4th
that cancels out and then of course the
condition number is one me this is
Trivial more or less condition number is
one and the training with how many steps
is this 10 steps you get 10^ minus 15
okay so this example was chosen in such
a way that you don't need to the
preconditioning here everything is exact
preconditioning works exactly uh this is
a very simple problem of course and a
very simple neural network model not
even a neural network Model F feature
model but the idea is very clear and you
can't solve this with neuron networks
such a simple problem if you take K to
be 100 you can't solve it because the
condition number is so so so so massive
okay so is that clear so this is and
I'll show you an example with neural
networks in a second so no chance
because of the intrinsic nature of the
physics inform training so this is with
neural networks I think let me look at
the distribution of values neural
networks these are genuine neuron
networks I think shallow neuron networks
one layer and Dage hyperbolic um
hyperbolic tangent function and
essentially you have lots of zero igen
values this is well known but uh the
point is if you don't precondition then
in this case um okay it's not as bad if
you take 500 epox then you get a loss of
about 10^ minus 3 which is uh what it is
but if you precondition that is if you
multiply the inverse of this Matrix so
essentially you take this in this
particular case it's small enough that
we can calculate this explicitly within
a few Epoch with 100 Epoch for instance
or less you get 10^ minus 5 in five five
Epoch so essentially even for neural
networks this this problem works because
of this uh point about preconditioning
so this is a very very simple problem
and this is another very simple problem
where you can see that it doesn't work
okay so this is uh UT Plus
beta of uux advection equation a wave
equation but with only one advecting
wave we know what the exact solution is
U of XT is nothing but U Bar the initial
conditions x minus bet T and now
everything depends on the speed of
infection so as fast as you move and in
fact you can explicitly compute so if
you take FIA features the same examples
that I gave you then you can explicitly
compute that um the behavior is like it
it is with respect to Beta it rises with
respect to Beta it is um and you can see
that for beta equal to 30 for instance
this is already um 100,000 you know so
it will require 100,000 steps which will
mean that it will never train and this
is indeed the case it never trains um
and you see that so for instance here is
an example so if you take um for
instance fua features no preconditioning
the knife version of FIA features this
is how the exact solution is so beta is
equal to 30 Pi so this is a high number
but okay so what so this is how the
solution behaves in space time so this
is space between minus 0 and 2 pi and
this is how it behaves in time so you
have waves that are moving but here it
simply doesn't work at all maybe in the
beginning there is something but as soon
as you go further you see complete noise
and the same if you take a neural
network if I take a MLP you don't see
any Behavior here because we know the
condition numbers are going to be very
very bad right because when is 30k the
condition number is like a million so it
will take a million steps and we can't
afford a million steps we have taken
thousand steps or something but then of
course if you precondition and in this
case you know exactly how to
precondition this you just divide with
the right quantity then it works like a
chart so you can see either here that uh
the loss within 50 pox it's already at
machine Precision so this this this
works quite well and uh whereas and you
also see it here that even if the speed
of advection is large you see that this
failure mode has been address so
preconditioning really works for this
simple problem and we leverage the fact
that it's a simple problem we know
everything about it we know exactly how
the condition number behaves what the
gram Matrix is and we could analytically
invert uh the same thing works also for
neural networks means um again the same
story that if you take bit 30 or 10 the
loss simply doesn't go down it's um of
the order of one whereas if you
precondition it then you start seeing
that uh this goes down okay so within
200 epox it's already at 10^ minus 6
which is which is which is quite good
and you see the same here so this was
without any preconditioning right
doesn't work except in the very
beginning and with preconditioning it
works very very well but again as I
emphasize that this can only be done
because we are able to have an explicit
structure of the problem for Navia
Stokes for complicated problems we don't
have uh we don't have access to this
exactly conditions and approximation is
people are still doing it means it's by
no means ready okay so I think that's
more or less what I have to say let me
go back to the summary so essentially
what I tried to do in the second half of
the lecture very quickly was to try and
open this black box essentially through
a simplified gradi in
descent but I I think it also told us
the story what we needed to do and
essentially training is uh ill
condition this is the main problem it's
ill condition because it depends on the
condition number of t St
D
essential and D itself as a just imagine
that if you take the Navia Stokes
equation it has some nonlinearity it has
some transport and so on and when you
take D star D first of all you get
fourth order derivatives you get
SpaceTime derivatives you get all kinds
of cross terms and we don't yet know how
to precondition these kind of problems
and for simple problems we can
precondition them we can precondition
the boplan for instance we know how to
do it from classical numerical analysis
from General linear problems I think we
can do it for nonlinear problems this is
completely open so essentially it says
that if you don't have complexity in
your solution either through the pde or
through the data you can use pins but as
soon as there is some complexity lots of
modes lots of um verticity and so on
either the training will fail or it will
fail to generalize so one should be very
very careful with with these methods
okay so I think I finished a bit earlier
but uh just five minutes earlier so if
you have any questions I'd be happy to
answer them also from people from the
chat otherwise uh from the next lecture
we we realize that these methods they
have lot of promise but they also have
enormous limitations as I just showed
you even for a person problem they don't
work so what's what's the point in some
sense so we have to change perspective
and we are going to change perspective
in the next lecture and since the PD
alone can't help us we have to rely on
data okay and that's that's going to be
its own challenge but this is what we're
going to do in the next lecture okay if
there are no questions we meet on Friday